c'est une toute petite rue de chartres
face à la cathédrale
elle n'est fréquenté que par les
connaisseurs des habitués bonjour
bienvenue chez sos poupe est malade nous
allons vous présenter à la fois notre
boutique où nous vendons des poupées et
des jouets est également notre activité
je vous en prie entrée c'est un endroit
étrange mystérieux comme un rêve éveillé
plus de 500 poupées qui vous dévisagent
certaines vous tendent les bras
sos poupée malades porte bien son nom
ici on traite aussi bien des bobologie
que des traumatismes chirurgie plastique
et réparatrice neuro chirurgie chirurgie
infantile chirurgie capillaires les
interventions recouvre de nombreuses
spécialités
quand on peut pas réparer on essaye de
retrouver la tête de la même époque de
la même marque de la même couleur de
celluloïd pour nous impossible de mettre
une tête qui ne correspond pas à
l'époque du corps là par contre on va
pouvoir refaire toute cette partie de la
phase donc remodeler le nez tous à la
bouche refaire à l'identique ce qu'on
appelle une restauration en
trompe-l'oeil donc dit invisible à
l'oeil nu autre exemple de réparation
c'est tout paix avec une tête de
porcelaine et le corps démembré sans des
poupées qui était monté sur élastique
dombes et blessures avec l'offre du
temps les élastiques finissent par
sécher et par lâcher donc là il va
falloir tour démonter et rechange et
tout le tout les élastiques
bonjour messieurs dames ah je vois la
petite ordonnance vous venez chercher
l'ours qui est maintenant guéri ici ici
à sa patte
voilà et bien finalement je vous ai
changé en fait toutes les articulations
ces bons l'ours quand j'étais petit très
petit je me souviens même plus à quel
âge je lui eus comme je vais à 63 ans
on peut supposer qu'il en à 61 ou 62
il était dans quel état en mauvais état
en très mauvais état
mais non mais c'est mon seul souvenirs
de quand j'étais petit koala il vous
tient que je pense que je vais en
prendre soin maintenant une période de
convalescence et des années ratant deux
sets plus
autre surprise dans cet antre du jouet
c'est la doyenne
elle date de 1850 une autre vedette
c'est la poupée bleus est alors bleus
est à exister de 1905 à 1960 et c'était
une poupée prime c'est à dire une poupée
lié à un magazine qui s'appelait la
semaine de suzette et c'est un monsieur
monsieur languereau qui a édité ce
magazine au moment du schisme entre
l'église et l'état
donc la revue donner des conseils aux
petites filles et présentait des
histoires en fait un épisode est
également des patrons pour habiller
cette petite poupée double est comme ça
cela permettait aux petites filles
d'apprendre la couture en famille
faisant elle souhaite poupée maladie une
clinique pour poupées et peluches mais
aussi une boutique musée plein de
souvenirs de rêve et d'histoire